the solar system is our home our local
neighborhood but it may surprise you to
know that we don't really understand how
far it extends when I was a kid I was
taught that where the planets were was
the solar system so that the farthest
planet at the time Pluto was where the
solar system stopped and it turns out
that's completely wrong if you think
that the solar system stops where the
planet stop where Neptune and Pluto are
you're missing the big picture literally
we're just coming to grips with a
stunning fact over 90% of our solar
system begins where the planets
End by the time the sun's Light reaches
out that far it's desperately
weak but we knew something was out there
because it kept sending us
visitors
comets
it was proposed that they came from a
mysterious disc out beyond the orbit of
Neptune but no one thought it would be
proven the Kyper belt was theoretical it
was thought to exist but it was also
thought that it would be too hard to
observe you're talking about objects
which may be a 100 miles across but
they're billions of miles away trying to
find something that's much much smaller
would be incredibly difficult and no one
really thought you could do it
in 1986 a team of astronomers based at
Hawaii's Mona Observatory decided to
prove them
wrong I'm a bit of a ho these are the
notes that uh we took while we were
observing I used to write lots of things
in a notebook to try to keep track of
everything that was happening on the
Mountaintop here's the name of the
telescope the 88 in telescope on Mona
also known as the rust
bucket visitors to that telescope always
think it's the ugliest thing they've
ever seen it's painted brown it looks
like it's totally Rusty parts of it are
Rusty so it's a horrible looking
telescope but we use it for all of our
work if they could locate an object
beyond the planets it would have to
inhabit the ghostly Kyper belt for 6
years they found nothing it was like
trying to find a rusty dime in the state
of Texas
we spent many many years looking for
objects in the outer solar system lots
of pain frankly lots of disappointment
you have to really have some respect for
the scale of objects yes we can see
stars that are hundreds or thousands of
light years away but there're these
giant glowing objects how do you see
something that's only 100 miles across
and it's dark it's not giving off any
visible light of its own that's why
finding these things have been
difficult Kyper belt objects are made of
mostly
ice so you'd think they'd Sparkle like
icebergs we're in a volcanic country so
some of these icebergs are actually dark
covered in Ash and they're a perfect
analogy for a Kyper belt object so I
really wanted to get close to this one
but my guides just told me that this
one's too big we can't get close it
might flip
over all right we found a really cool
one it's really dark let's get over here
so you see how black this thing is on
the outside well comets are also black
but actually they're even blacker than
this we think that comets typically are
blacker than asphalt blacker than
tar the ink black Kyper belt objects
stayed hidden for half a
decade then One Summer Night JW and his
team spotted something and the solar
system would never be the
same so here's the log sheet uh the
notes that we keep while we're
observing 29th of August
1992 we started as normal looking at the
images as they came out of the telescope
and found this first object it was a
single tiny dot moving very slowly
across the sky and its slow path showed
it was orbiting the Sun but in an orbit
that took it way Beyond the planets an
orbit that would put it in the
mysterious Kyper belt it was moving
incredibly slowly across the sky and
therefore was incredibly far away and we
knew just from the slow speed we knew
immediately it was the most distant
object ever seen in the solar system up
to that
point here's this note Smo slow moving
object question mark so that's the
discovery of the Kyper belt right there
with those three tiny little
letters in in an instant the Kyper belt
became real and our solar system became
twice as
large it was groundbreaking because now
we have this this whole part of the
solar system that we had predicted but
had no evidence for boom
evidence the discovery of the first
Kyper Bel object was a clear indication
that there is this new population of
objects out there basically overnight we
doubled the diameter of the solar system
the team later identified several other
Kyper belt objects they calculated there
must be billions orbiting the Sun in a
vast dis it was our first proof that our
solar system had giant surprises in
store for us way way way Beyond where we
thought the solar system
ended the discovery of the first Kyper
belt object was a fantastic achievement
it was observational proof that there
was an entire population of objects out
in the solar system that we thought
might exist and then found out truly did
it would be as big as discovering
another full-fledged
Planet the discovery of the Kyper belt
instantly inflated the size of the solar
system but deflated the status of one
member because some of the objects in
the belt were bigger than our smallest
planet
Pluto was demoted to dwarf
planet I have actually really enjoyed
the controversy about what do you call
Pluto is it a planet is it a dwarf
planet is it something in between it
shows people still care Pluto is still
fascinating is still an important part
of our solar system but now we see it in
the context of its nearest neighbors
let's not get angry that Pluto's no
longer labeled a planet let's get
interested in the fact that Pluto is a
dwarf planet and can teach us lots of
things about all of its new friends that
we're discovering year after year after
year Pluto now has over 1,400 brothers
and sisters called
plutinos if Pluto's a planet all the
plutinos are too so I have a daughter it
would be very painful for her to try to
remember all those
names the discovery of the Kyper belt
opened up the solar system but it was
only the start of our journey of
exploration to the outer
reaches
[Music]
the Kyper belt extends about 50 times
farther out from the Sun than the
Earth's distance from the Sun it's huge
but if you think the edge of the Kyper
belt is the edge of the solar system
you're thinking way too
small Way Beyond the Kyper belt the sun
has actually deployed a deflector shield
around the solar system our star is
waging a cosmic war against the biggest
guns in the galaxy and our lives depend
on it
winning